في اطاره مواصله تغطيه قناه العربيه لما
يجري في تويتر نحن مازلنا موجودين هنا قرب
المقر الرئيسي في مدينه سان فرانسيسكو
لرصد اخر التطورات اهم الاخبار التي
سمعناها مؤخرا هي ما نقلته وسائله اعلام
الامريكيه عن الى الماسك نفسه الذي قال ان
مرحله اليقالات قد انتهت والان ستبدا
مرحله التوظيف واعطى الاولويه لتوظيف
المهندسين
والتوظيف في قسم المبيعات امرا اختلفت
عليه القرع
اعتقد ان الامر فريت هناك كثيرون تمت
اقالتهم ثم الان هناك توظيف لاشخاص جدد قد
يكون ذلك امرا جيدا لمعرفه ما يمكن تعيينه
اذا كنت لا تريد العوده الى العمل
والاحتفاظ به فهناك كثيرون في المدينه
يبحثون عن وظيفه
باكثر من قيمتها والان يختلق الامور وسيصل
الى مرحله لا تكون لديه سنه نقديه
حاولنا خلال الايام الماضيه اكثر من مره
ان نتواصل مع احد في الشركه لكن رجال
الامن هنا الامن المنطقه يمنعوننا سنحاول
مره اخرى الدخول الى ااا الشركه لنتواصل
مع احد المديرين او احد الموظفين الذين
يمكن ان يساعدونا على فهم ما يجري اكثر
خاصه في ظل التطورات الاخيره نحن الان
نقترب من باب الشركه شاهد ان البعض يشير
الينا ربما يقترب منا ايه موظفون الامن
وبالفعل هذا ما يحدث الان ليمنعنا لا اعرف
لماذا لا يقبلون التحدث لا يعطون اي اشاره
او ذلك
اوكي
امين
الكاميرا ياتون ويحاولون منعنا من دخول في
المرات السابقه حتى عندما اتيت بدون
كاميرا رفضوا التحدث اليه عندما عرفوا
انني الصحافه يعني هذا هو الحال الحالي
دائما
هي تسريبات من بعض الموظفين الذين تكلمون
لكن بشرط ان لا همم تذكر اسماءهم ولكن
هؤلاء التواصل معهم ان يكون صعب يخوفهم من
ان يعرف همم يعرف او شيء من هذا القبيل
الحسين من امام مقر سان فرانسيسكو العربيه
يعني